[Musique]
pendant deux siècles la france a
construit sa richesse sur ses usines
ce passé industriel a profondément
marqué notre territoire
il se lit encore dans ces paysages et
sans doute pour très longtemps encore
dans son sol un de remuer la vase
gaillard et en un véritable nuage
d'hydrocarbures sur la surface de
hydrocarbures solvants des produits
toxiques peuvent dormir sous nos pieds
sans que nous en ayons la moindre idée
et parfois même dans des établissements
scolaires
ce camp iv volant un grand j convention
deux tiers des friches industrielles
seraient encore pollué les populations
qui vivent autour sont elles protégées
at on vraiment tirer les leçons du passé
pendant six mois une commission
d'enquêté sénatoriale a dressé un état
des lieux de la pollution des sols en
france et son constat est très claire il
faut qu'en se dotant d'un outil
législatif qui permettent de mettre les
personnes de valeur responsabilité pour
les stars ne l'a pas
[Musique]
un mi chemin entre toulouse et albi le
village de couffouleux d'un côté son
centre ville pittoresque de l'autre sa
zone industrielle
c'est ici que vit christian soulié
il y a trente ans il a vu s'installer un
nouveau voisin de l'autre côté de sa
clôture aujourd'hui fermé l'entreprise
en du skol fabriquer des savons
détergents et lubrifiant à base de
liquides dangereux des produits qui vont
très vite inquiéter christian soulié
ce qui nous gêne et terriblement et ceux
qui nous donnaient de grosses craintes
et l'évidente que qui étaient
entreposées ici sur des racques sur
trois étages environ c'est évident comme
vous pouvez le constater il ya le parc
gautier n'y avait pas quoi que ce soit
donc qu'ils étaient exposés au soleil
aux intempéries à la pluie et cetera
donc une oxydation très importante et
envoyer les sentiments qui se produisait
surtout les villes ont imaginé un peu
tous ces produits chimiques qui se
déverse sur le sol quand on voit l'eau
qui stagne de la pluie
on imagine tout ça mélangé des produits
chimiques ce que ça peut donner
un cocktail explosif à quelques mètres
de son jardin et de son puits pendant
des années christian soulié vit dans la
crainte permanente d'un incendie
certaine époque la température était
très chaude on importe il y avait de
fortes odeurs de produits chimiques ça
leur santé profondément oui vu les
écoulements constatés sur les sur les
fuis moi j'ai de fortes craintes sur ce
qui est des infiltrations de pollution
dans l'eau dans le sol week end jusqu'à
l'été pourtant une entreprise connue des
autorités
la dangerosité des produits stockés et
manipuler on faisait une installation
classée pour la protection de
l'environnement
c'est à dire un site soumis à
autorisation préfectorale et surtout à
une réglementation spécifique
christian soulié se tournent donc vers
les autorités qui vont se révéler
impuissante face à un exploitant peu
scrupuleux ce que je sais je dis bien
c'est qu'aucune tentative de contrôle
n'a abouti puisque rien ne s'est passé
pendant les vendanges ce monsieur était
là et personne à se présenter que ce
soit la gendarmerie que ce soit avec
contrôleur ou autre ces personnes sont
toujours restés au portail n'ont jamais
eu un an jamais pu procéder à quoi que
ce soit alertée par le voisinage
le maire de couffouleux a demandé
l'intervention de la direction régionale
de l'environnement
la dre elle chargée de surveiller les
installations classées on avait bien eu
des interventions la dréal mais qui en
fait n'ont absolument pas abouti puisque
eux-mêmes l'amba nous on ne sait pas
comment faire
on peut frison fait à priori tout ce
qu'ils pouvaient ça pose vraiment des
questions sur la capacité de l'état à
pouvoir intervenir dans ce genre de
situation
les inspecteurs de la dréal ont-ils
vraiment été empêchés d'entrer sur le
site
malgré un risque avéré de pollution des
sols nous avons posé la question à la
préfecture du tarn
voici sa réponse le site n'a pas été
exploité conformément aux dispositions
réglementaires en vigueur
le travail de l'inspection s'est
régulièrement heurter à des difficultés
d'accès au site
en raison de l'absence de l'exploitant
ou de son refus de laisser libre l'accès
du site
quatre inspections n'ont ainsi pu
aboutir entre 2011 et 2018 comment une
installation classée à risques at elle
pu bafoué les normes environnementales
les plus élémentaires
sous le regard impuissant des
inspecteurs de l'état après six mois
d'enquêté sur la pollution des sols
gisèle jourda n'est pas surprise par
l'exemple de couffouleux ça ne m'étonne
pas du tout c'est le même schéma qui se
reproduit partout à bretagne où donc
dans le pas de calais vous y trouverez
le même désarroi des personnes
la même incapacité et surtout la même
paralyse ibnou pouvoirs publics une
paralysie qui s'explique par un droit
lacunaire alors que l'air et l'eau sont
considérés comme des biens communs le
sol reste attaché à la propriété privée
c'est l'un des principaux constats de la
commission d' enquête sénatoriale qui
propose d'inscrire la protection des
sols dont la loi française
je pense très sincèrement qu'il faut
qu'on se dote d'un outil législatif qui
permettent de mettre les personnes
devant leurs responsabilités
il n'est pas possible à quelqu'un qui a
exploité un site pendant des années puis
qui anime plusieurs propriétaires dieu
pas donné les clés de la maison mobilité
du terrain pour pouvoir donc qu'ils
aient pénétré à l'intérieur
il n'est absolument pas possible que
dalle outils législatifs on n'est pas un
outil contraignant pour les stars on ne
l'a pas
face à un industriel récalcitrants il
faut attendre la cessation de l'activité
de l'entreprise pour intervenir à
couffouleux tout a changé en 2018
avec la mort de l'exploitant pour la
première fois les services de l'état
vont pouvoir entrer dans le bâtiment
spider man land et après y avait pas eu
des trucs hyper exotiques
en l'absence d'héritier 1 du skol est
devenu un site dits orphelins sans
propriétaire dans ce cas l'ademe
l'agencé de la transition écologique est
mandaté pour évaluer les risques de
pollution
graphiquement la dm interviennent
lorsque on est sur une installation
classée lorsqu'il ya défaillance de
l'exploitant ça c'est un point clipse
qu'en fin de compte en droit français il
ya toujours le principe de
responsabilité le pollueur doit être le
payeur
là pour le coup sachant qu'il ya eu
décès et que la liquidation ne pouvait
pas être prononcée qui avait une vraie
un vrai danger un vrai risque
environnemental l'état a mandaté l'ademe
pour assurer cette mise en sécurité
on avait quand même des produits qu'ils
étaient capables de bien attaquer les
métaux oued au curage à l'âme elle est
obligée là la mise en sécurité consiste
à éliminer tout risque pour
l'environnement ou pour les riverains
un chantier confié dans ce cas à
l'entreprise suez chargée d'évacuer tous
les déchets on a de l'incinération on a
des flux qui partent en valorisation
énergétique en cimenterie
on a certains éléments qui peuvent être
régénérées ou ce genre de choses
sept différents types de différentes
façons de traiter les différents déchets
en fonction de leurs caractéristiques et
des risques qu'elles présentent
ça a quand même bien navas et ça fait du
bien parce que c'est quand même c'était
catastrophique là quand même
on a beaucoup de conditionnement faire
ils sont rouillés grippe et donc on
n'arrive plus à ouvrir
on est obligé de détériorer comme
celui-là derrière et dans la rétention
là bas on a les pleins de bidons de
l'histoire et du nitrite ducos floride
de leur historique
ces contenants sont susceptibles de
s'ouvrir on n'est pas du tout sûr de
l'état de la dalle et pita sur le sol
environnant est très proche et en
revanche en plus il y avait en un
problème d'eau souterraines ou
souterraines et à proximité il ya 2 puis
1 puis ici puis un pichet le voisin donc
on va ouvrir aussi un vrai risque de
pollution des autres de par le
renversement ou l'épanchement de ces
produits là sur le sol
il ya quand même un gros gros boulot de
nettoyage qui il reste encore pas mal de
travail
café qu'on a les résultats du labo les
analyses de l'ademe diront si les sols
ont été touchés par l'activité
industrielle le travail de lagence
s'arrêtera là son rôle se limite à lait
mise en sécurité des sites orphelins
elle ne finance pas la dépollution
intéressé par le terrain pour les
besoins de la commune le maire sait
qu'il n'aura pas les moyens d'assainir
les sols s'il s'avère contaminer notre
crainte c'est que ce terrain devienne
une friche qui restent telles qu'elles
parce que personne ne veut ne veut
s'engager
je crains en effet fortement que l'état
dise non on va le laisser comme ça on va
laisser en plan des sites orphelins qui
se transforme en friche industrielle
polluée
la france en compte des dizaines
peut-être même des centaines personne ne
sait vraiment combien
le recensement n'a jamais été fait mais
une chose est sûre certains territoires
en comptent plus que d'autres
[Musique]
mais tu vois pas là si tu la voulais
avoir la vache à son os la vache
grand les coûts hydrocarbures qui alla
la teneur en hydrocarbures dans cette
cette vase se sont pas glissés sur la le
bois ouais
un de remuer la vase regarder
en un véritable nuage d'hydrocarbures
sur le sur la surface 2
bon alors ici on est dans l'ancien bras
mort de la moselle
là il ya des oiseaux il ya toute une
faune et une flore qui est elle un
moment donné on avait même des castors
donc qui étaient là mais ils sont pas
resté très longtemps les castors pas
longtemps un dixième pas les sols
pollués et ses hydrocarbures sont
provenus d'un site que nous avons de
l'autre côté qui traitait les huiles
usagées le site pétrodollars bol
à quelques dizaines de mètres impossible
de rater la friche petro carbone à
l'entrée de dieulouard le maire de la
ville
il reçoit la visite de jean françois
husson membre de la commission d'
enquête sur la pollution des sols c'est
le contrôle après a dit qu'ils ont fait
depuis et à la même 3 tu vois alors ça a
été fermée par l'ademe non non ils vont
plonger de temps en temps ils vont
pomper de l'eau pour regarder 6 à 2 de
l'hydrocarbure dessus accord sur les
trois là c'est fortement encore
fortement après la fermeture du site en
1996 le propriétaire a soigneusement
organisé sa disparition depuis l'ademe à
démanteler les bâtiments et évacuer les
déchets mais elle ne peut financer à
elles seules l'excavation des terres
évalué à plus d'un million d'euros sur
les sites orphelins
c'est au nouveau propriétaire de
dépolluer les sols pour qu'un acheteur
soit prêt à payer
il faut que le terrain soit suffisamment
rentable cantonné sur un site en
territoire rural ou éloignées des grands
centres urbains
la complexité elle vient finalement de
la difficulté d'avoir un équilibre
financier en clair l'état est absent
les collectivités ne peuvent pas se
permettre ni un opérateur privé désirons
là où c'est plus facile désirons en
ville notamment là où la rentabilité est
écrit d'avancé
en l'absence de promoteurs intéressés le
site petrocaribe hall est en friche
depuis des années
la mairie qui a prévu de construire 150
logements juste à côté aurait pourtant
bien besoin du terrain dessiné
normalement ton projet à cet endroit la
torah quoi ici on fait un parking sauf
que tu vas voir après en face à un
problème de coût là bas là il ya un vrai
problème ici c'est un problème donné
en gros ils ont déjà abordé avec toi
l'ademe la question du coût oui alors on
a on a abordé la fourchette entre 1
million et 1 million 5 1 de la
dépollution du site
aujourd'hui plusieurs co financeurs
publics dont l'ademe sont prêts à
s'engager pour la dépollution de petro
carbone il demande à la mairie de
dieulouard de participer à hauteur de 20
% soit trois cent mille euros
impossible assure le maire
trois cent mille euros c'est un tiers du
budget annuel d'investissement de sa
commune est-ce qu'on a les moyens
bah non ça veut dire si jamais on vient
dé à dépolluer ici participer à la
dépollution c'est des investissements
qu'on ne fait pas il ya qui sont
nécessaires et indispensables pour la
collectivité
je demande à l'état chacun de s'engager
pour nous aider et dépolluer ce site
pour aider les communes 1 dépolluer les
sites orphelins la commission d' enquête
sénatoriale propose de prélever une
partie des taxes et un monde sur les
activités polluantes
on a souhaité en tous les cas on a
estimé qu'avec un fonds de 75 millions
chaque année on pouvait enclencher la
démarche
évidemment ça veut dire qu'il faut
définir des priorités mais l'objectif
c'est bien le traitement de ces sites
industriels pollués pour permettre aux
communes de donner une nouvelle destinée
à c'est hélas
ici la pollution est encore bien visible
mais certaines usines ont disparu bien
plus discrètement sans qu'aucune
précautions soient prises avant d'y
reconstruire des maisons voire même des
établissements scolaires la restauration
avait également plus aucun élève n'a mis
les pieds au collège saint-exupéry de
vincennes depuis trois ans en 2017 le
département du val de marne ans des
travaux de rénovation qui vont mettre à
jour une bien mauvaise surprise
nous avions réceptionné les travaux fin
août avec les chantiers d'été
nous sommes venus visiter et c'est à
cette occasion que malheureusement les
services m'ont informé que il y aura un
problème pour continuer la
réhabilitation du collège la
satisfaction a été de courte durée
[Musique]
des analyses des sols liée aux travaux
révèlent une pollution au
trichloréthylène l'héritage bien cachée
d'une ancienne activité industrielle
dont personne n'est les connaissances la
pollution la plus concentrée se trouve
juste devant nos là où se trouvaient les
anciens ateliers des activités
industriel le trichloréthylène a
contaminé les eaux puis par évaporation
les guest du sol ce solvant peut
s'avérer cancérigène
plus l'exposition est forte et prolongée
plus le risque augmente le danger ici
c'est qu'il stagne dans les bâtiments
notamment au rez-de-chaussée donc c'est
là où on peut avoir les plus grandes
expositions avec des taux d'une centaine
de microgrammes par mètre cube à
plusieurs milliers de microgrammes par
mètre cube c'est équivalent à plus de 10
cents fois où mille fois ce qu'on peut
observer en cas d'absence de pollution
de ce type là d'après les autorités
sanitaires le niveau d'exposition des
élèves qui ont étudié ici ne présente
pas de danger pour leur santé
mais le personnel qui a exercé pendant
des années dans l'établissement est
inquiet
à l'origine de cette pollution une
simple usine de fabrication d'objets
métalliques disparu dans les années 70
avant la construction du collège
discrètement c'était surprenant parce
que c'était pas un site répertorié comme
pouvant avoir une dimension polluantes
quoi donc voilà on s'est trouvé un petit
peu sur frais il existe pourtant
plusieurs bases de données relatives à
la pollution des sols mais aucune ne
mentionnait cette petite usine
malgré son riche passé industriel la
france ne dispose pas d'une cartographie
complète des sites pollués
c'est l'un des principaux enseignements
du rapport de la commission d'enquêté
sénatoriale
moi je plaide pour une cartographie
parce qu'il n'y en a pas actuellement on
a des croisements de bilam et de données
mais qui sont ce qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
on a besoin en france d'une cartographie
bien clair et bien-être pour qu'on sache
qu est-ce qu il y adonnent au sol
comment on peut y vivent
parce que nous vivrons toujours avec le
risque de la pollution faut pas croire
que la pollution des sols ou de l'air ou
de l'eau
on va les chasser
combien d'autres établissements
scolaires ont été construits sur un site
pollué depuis 2009
la loi oblige l'état à les recenser
c'est un acquis du grenelle de
l'environnement
en 2010 le gouvernement lance alors une
grande campagne d'identification
la méthode est simple croisé
l'inventaire des anciens sites
industriels nommé base yes avec la carte
des établissements accueillant des
enfants de la crèche au lycée cela
permet d'identifier plus de 2000
établissements sensibles
situé sur un site potentiellement
pollués dans chacun d'entre eux une
étude doit être mené pour vérifier
l'état des sols les établissements
diagnostiqués sont classées en trois
catégories à le sol n'est pas pollué b
dépollution existent sont danger
immédiat et nécessite des mesures
techniques c'est la présence de
polluants nécessite des mesures
techniques voire sanitaire dans certains
cas la fermeture au moins temporaires
s'imposent
la crèche henri ribière dans le 19e
arrondissement parisien fait partie des
établissements classés en catégorie c en
2016 les analyses menées par les
services de l'état révèle la présence de
polluants dans les sous sol de
l'établissement et donc ses pieds désert
il plonge dans le sol qui est situé sous
la crèche et dans le cas des pieds
désert ils vont mesurer c'est ça les
polluants qui sont dans l'air contenu
dans le sol exactement
cette crèche a été construite sur une
ancienne manufacture du son si l'enfer
on y retrouve la même substance
cancérigène qu'au collège de vincennes
le trichloréthylène au delà de 10
microgrammes par mètre cube
il faut intervenir rapidement pour les
mesures réalisées dans l'air lors de la
dernière campagne de mesure on est ici à
un peu plus de 30 microgrammes par mètre
cube de trichloréthylène forte
heureusement c'est une pièce qui est
fréquenté de façon très occasionnel par
les personnels qui peuvent venir y
chercher ou y apporter du matériel mais
cependant la persistance de niveaux
élevés justifie qu'on mette en oeuvre
les travaux de dépollution
les enfants n'ont donc pas été exposé au
trichloréthylène présent uniquement dans
les sous sols mais pour protéger le
personnel
la crèche restera fermée encore un an le
temps de dépolluer les sols
si on n'avait pas eu cette réalisation
de diagnostics systématique
on aurait pu passer à côté au moins de
la présence de la source de pollution
dans le band sol
sans ce diagnostic financé par l'état la
crèche serait donc sans doute encore
ouverte mais tous les établissements
parisiens situé sur un ancien site
industriel n'ont pas pu en bénéficier
à paris la quasi totalité des crèches a
fait l'objet du diagnostic
par contre les écoles n'ont pas encore
été diagnostiqué ni les collèges en 2016
la campagne d'identification des
établissements à risque n'est pas
achevée mais le gouvernement décide d'y
mettre fin prématurément alors qu'elle a
permis de recenser plus de 2000
établissements situés sur un site
potentiellement pollués seul 1359 ont
fait l'objet d'un diagnostic dans un
tiers des établissements à risques
aucune étude des sols n'a donc été
réalisée à ce jour
motif la poursuite des diagnostics
coûterait 40 millions d'euros
trop pour ségolène royal qui est alors
ministre de l'environnement
plusieurs voix s'élèvent pour lui
demander de revenir sur sa décision
en vain
dans cet email que s'est procuré la
commission d'enquêté sénatoriale
elle s'adresse au préfet de police de
paris par votre courrier du 24 octobre
2016 vous avez appelé mon attention sur
l'intérêt de poursuivre les diagnostics
des sols des établissements accueillant
des populations sensibles
compte tenu des contraintes budgétaires
pesant sur le ministère dans un contexte
de réduction des déficits publics
j'ai décidé de ne pas renouveler la
démarche c'est une faute
une forte magistral jamais je ne
voudrais que mes petits enfants que les
enfants de mes voisins que vivent dans
un univers et sur des sites pollués sans
qu'on ne fasse rien plus étonnant encore
toute l'ancienne région rhône alpes a
été écarté de la démarche sur le site
qui recense les établissements sensibles
une recherche sur l'isr ne donne par
exemple aucun résultat contacté par
email la mairie de grenoble semble
découvrir l'existence de la démarche
établissements sensibles
la ville de grenoble n'a pas été informé
de ce diagnostic par les services de
l'état
elle va saisir le ministère afin d'avoir
de plus amples informations sur celui ci
[Musique]
rhône savoie ardèche dans huit
départements
les établissement construit sur un
ancien site industriel n'ont pas été
recensés
pas plus que les écoles et les collèges
parisiens dans la capitale seuls les
crèches ont pu bénéficier de la démarche
la mairie de paris a donc décidé de
procéder elle même au diagnostic
nous avons considéré que notre
responsabilité
c'était de nous substituer au
désengagement de l'état pour poursuivre
cette campagne dont le coût est
conséquent puisque c'est environ 10000
euros par établissement
coût de l'opération 2,6 millions d'euros
pour diagnostiquer 260 établissements à
partir de 2021
d'autres communes plus modestes n'ont
sans doute pas les moyens de lancer de
telles études
dans son rapport la commission enquête
sénatoriale demande au gouvernement de
débloquer 50 millions d'euros pour
reprendre les diagnostics des
établissements à risques partout sur le
territoire
cet inventaire qui a été abandonnée on
se doit donc de le de le réinscrire et
de demander au gouvernement que soit une
priorité d'inscrire la somme donc
voulue au budget le gouvernement est il
prêt à reprendre cette campagne suspendu
il ya quatre ans le ministère de la
transition écologique a refusé notre
demande d'interview
alors nous avons posé la question
directement à barbara compilé parce que
votre votre ministère envisage de la
reprendre comme le sénat lee a invité à
écouter je vais voir cette demande
puisque cette demande n'est pas parvenue
jusqu'à moi donc je vais regarder ça
près et puis je vous tiendrai au courant
ces équipes ont pourtant bien reçu le
rapport de la commission denquête
sénatoriales en septembre plus d'un mois
avant le tournage de ce documentaire
la balle est désormais dans le camp du
ministère de la transition écologique
il revient à barbara pompili de
reprendre ou non le diagnostic de
pollution des sols dans les
établissements scolaires et pourquoi pas
d'ouvrir le chantier d'une vraie loi sur
la protection des sols aujourd'hui
absente de notre législation
[Musique]